>>> DUELING CAMPAIGN RALLIES IN
ARIZONA OVER THE WEEKEND FOR
REPUBLICAN GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATES KARI LAKE.
MIKE PENCE, CHRIS CHRISTIE AND
DOUG DUCEY HAVE ENDORSED TAYLOR
ROBSON.
KARRIN TAYLOR ROBSON IS JOINING
US NOW.
YOU HEAR HOW PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
THE RACE YOU'RE IN.
IT'S BILLED AS A PROXY WAR.
DO YOU SEE IT THAT WAY?
>> YOU KNOW, THIS ELECTION IS
ABOUT ARIZONA AND THE FUTURE OF
ARIZONA, AND I'M JUST PROUD TO
HAVE THE ENDORSEMENT OF PEOPLE
LIKE VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
AND A LONG LINEUP NOW OF
GOVERNORS AND FORMER GOVERNORS,
THEY KNOW SPECIFICALLY WHAT IT
TAKES TO LEAD A STATE.
I'M JUST HONORED TO HAVE THEIR
SUPPORT AND ENDORSEMENT.
>> POLICYWISE, WHAT SETS YOU
APART FROM KARI LAKE?
>>.
>> THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE IS I
HAVE A 30-YEAR OF ACCOMPLISHMENT
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR, BUILDING
BUDGETS, RUNNING TEAMS, SIGNING
BOTH SIDES OF PAYCHECKS.
I HAVE A LONG, LONG HISTORY AND
RECORD OF SUPPORTING REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES AND CONSERVATIVE
CAUSES.
THAT'S WHY I'M IN THIS RACE, TO
MOVE ARIZONA FORWARD AND BRING A
CONSERVATIVE VISION TO OUR
STATE.
>> WHICH IS REALLY A DIFFERENCE
OF EXPERIENCE THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING TO THE JOB, RIGHT?
ON POLICIES, LET'S TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION, FOR INSTANCE.
YOU'RE BOTH IN FAVOR OF BUILDING
THE WALL.
YOU'RE IN FAVOR OF SURGING THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
ARE THERE DIFFERENCES THERE?
>> LAST WEEK WE OBTAINED THE
ENDORSEMENT OF THE BORDER PATROL
COUNCIL.
THEY KNOW I CAN GET IT DONE
BECAUSE OF MY RECORD OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
LAKE SUPPORTED AMNESTY FOR 11
MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SHE AND I.
NOT ONLY DID SHE SUPPORT AMNESTY
FOR 1 IS MILLION PEOPLE, SHE
WALKED DOORS AND SUPPORTED
BARACK OBAMA WHILE I WAS OUT
SUPPORTING AND WORKING FOR
CONSERVATIVE CANDIDATES.
WE JUST HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
DIFFERENCES.
>> AND NOW SHE'S TALKING ABOUT
SENDING ARMED NATIONAL GUARD TO
THE BORDER.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN YOU SAY, IN YOUR
PLATFORM, THAT YOU WANT TO SURGE
THE NATIONAL GUARD, SENDING
ARMED NATIONAL GUARD TO THE
BORDER?
>> WE WILL SEND NATIONAL GUARD
TO THE BORDER AND THEY'LL BE
THERE IN A SUPPORT ROLE FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
ARIZONA ARE BEING OVERRUN.
WE ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
WHAT IS REALLY A 50-STATE CRISIS
WITH THE SURGE AND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CROSSING OUR BORDERS.
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES ALONG THE
BORDER, THEY'RE GETTING THE
BRUNT OF THIS.
AND SO WE WILL DO EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER.
IN FACT, THE FIRST THING I WILL
DO AS GOVERNOR IS CALL AN
EMERGENCY SESSION OF OUR
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
DOWN THERE, INCLUDING SURGING
THE NATIONAL GUARD.
>> LET'S TALK ELECTION
INTEGRITY.
YOUR OPPONENT SAYS SHE WOULDN'T
HAVE CERTIFIED THE ELECTION IF
SHE WERE GOVERNOR, AS GOVERNOR
DOUG DUCEY DID.
WOULD YOU HAVE CERTIFIED THE
ELECTION?
>> WELL, I'M A LAWYER.
I'M A TRAINED LAWYER.
I CAN'T SIT HERE AND TELL YOU
WITHOUT HAVING BEEN PRESENTED
ALL THE EVIDENCE, BUT THERE HAS
BEEN INVESTIGATION AFTER
INVESTIGATION AND ARE THERE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE FIXED?
ABSOLUTELY.
WE'VE GOT TO -- WE HAVE TO
REQUIRE VOTER I.D.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD.
I'M LOOKING AT 2022 AND DOING
EVERYTHING I CAN TO KEEP
ARIZONA'S GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
REPUBLICAN HANDS.
THAT REQUIRES US TO LOOK FORWARD
AND ARTICULATE A VISION FOR THE
FUTURE OF THIS STATE.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN FOCUSED
ON.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT LOOKING
FORWARD, OF COURSE, BUT LOOKING
FORWARD IS DONALD TRUMP VERY
LIKELY RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
AGAIN.
THIS IS AN ENTIRELY PERTINENT
QUESTION.
WOULD YOU HAVE CERTIFIED THE
ELECTION AS GOVERNOR?
>> AGAIN, LIKE I SAID, I WASN'T
SITTING THERE, AS GOVERNOR DOUG
DUCEY WAS PRESENTED WITH ALL THE
EVIDENCE.
I HAVE TO CONSIDER BASED ON --
>> YOU'VE SEEN THE EVIDENCE.
YOU'VE SEEN THE RESULTS OF
AUDITS.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE INFORMATION
COMING OUT OF ARIZONA.
HE ENDORSED YOU.
>> THERE ARE INVESTIGATIONS THAT
ARE ONGOING.
AND I TELL EVERYBODY, WHEN ASKED
THIS QUESTION AROUND THE STATE
OF ARIZONA, MY FOCUS IS ON
LOOKING FORWARD.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET STUCK
LOOKING IN THE REARVIEW MIRROR.
I AM FOCUSED ON LOOKING FORWARD
AND MAKING SURE WE DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO ELECT A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR IN ARIZONA, TO NOMINATE
A REPUBLICAN THAT CAN WIN IN
NOVEMBER.
THAT IS MY FOCUS.
>> OKAY, BUT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
IMPORTANT -- THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION AGAIN THAT
ISN'T NECESSARILY A LUXURY WE
HAVE OF JUST LOOKING FORWARD IN
THIS CASE.
DO YOU ACCEPT THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION OF 2020?
>> WE HAVE THE WRONG GUY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND I --
>> DO YOU -- SORRY, GO ON.
>> SO, YOU KNOW, OUR
CONSTITUTION PROVIDES FOR ONE
PRESIDENT AT A TIME.
AND I BELIEVE THE WRONG
PRESIDENT IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
IN FACT, THAT'S WHY I HAVE GIVEN
UP MY CAREER --
>> BUT WRONGFULLY --
>> TO RUN FOR GOVERNOR BECAUSE I
WANT TO GET RID OF JOE BIDEN.
>> YOU THINK HE'S THE WRONG GUY
IN THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> WRONGFULLY ELECTED OR
RIGHTFULLY ELECTED, WRONG GUY
FOR THE JO BE?
JOB?
>> THE 2020 ELECTION AT A
MINIMUM WAS NOT FAIR.
THAT'S MY CONSISTENT ANSWERS.
WE HAD THE MEDIA SUPPRESSING
NEWS.
I DON'T NEED TO SAY ANYTHING
OTHER THAN HUNTER BIDEN.
WE HAD BIG TECH SILENCING
CONSERVATIVE VOICES.
WE HAD JUDGES ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY CHANGING THE RULES IN
THE DAYS AND THE WEEKS AND THE
MONTHS LEADING UP TO THE
ELECTION UNDER THE -- BECAUSE OF
COVID AND THE CHAOS THAT
SURROUNDED COVID.
AT A MINIMUM, IT WASN'T FAIR.
WE ALSO HAD MARK ZUCKERBERG
SPENDING NEARLY HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPRESS VOTER
TURNOUT ACROSS THIS COUNTRY,
INCLUDING IN ARIZONA.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS TOGETHER
CONSPIRED TO HAVE 78% OF THE
REPUBLICANS IN ARIZONA THINKING
SOMETHING WAS WRONG WITH THE
ELECTION.
I ALSO AM QUITE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO DO IN
UPCOMING ELECTIONS.
NOW THAT HE HAS SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTING EVERY
AGENCY OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO INCREASE VOTER TURNOUT AND
REGISTRATION IN THE SAME TYPES
OF PRECINCTS THAT MARK
ZUCKERBERG SPENT HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS.
I'M FOCUSED ON WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IN THE FUTURE.
>> BEFORE I LET YOU GO, DO YOU
ACCEPT THE OUTCOME OF THE 2020
ELECTION?
>> WE HAVE THE WRONG GUY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THAT'S ALL I'M GOING TO SAY ON
THAT.
THAT'S WHY I'M RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR.
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE WHO'S IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND ARIZONA NEEDS TO STAY IN
REPUBLICAN HANDS SO THAT WE CAN
KICK HIM OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
IN 2024.
>> ALL RIGHT.
KARRIN TAYLOR ROBSON, WE
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.